[Musique]
chaque matin
Ivana une enfant de 8 ans dispose de la
patinoire de Bourges pour elle toute
seule depuis la semaine dernière elle
est la championne de France de patinage
artistique et là quand on arrive
première au championnat de France
qu'est-ce que ça fait
du bien c'est comme une récompense
Ivana travaille dur depuis 3 ans à
Bourges avec sa maman l'entraînement est
plutôt en russe
on voulait que la sa passion aussi comme
nous
on essayait tôt mais au final on a eu un
les concerts à New York on est resté
avec notre orchestre pendant trois
semaines et du coup on se promenait un
petit peu et dans le centre parc elle a
vu le personnage la patinoire
en fait j'étais allée sur les patins
j'ai dit maman lâche-moi parce que je me
tenais sur les patins je voulais glisser
et j'ai senti que je j'étais bien
au théâtre Saint-Bonnet elle a le droit
de jouer sur le piano de son grand-père
Dada le grand-père le voici Franck il a
composé la valse d'Ivana au retour du
manège quand elle était petite
naturellement elle grimpe sur le cheval
le bois
aujourd'hui au théâtre Mozart à
l'honneur Maximilien le papa travaille
sur un disque avec Pierre Génisson le
célèbre Clarine est iste tu as beaucoup
voyagé
le concert quand il y avait pas encore
la musique bah moi je sais y aller tout
le temps sur la scène et je danse
du monde
de patinage artistique fait de la
musculation de la danse du patin elle
aime la musique elle garde son sourire
d'enfant mais elle sait ce qu'est la
passion